the equilibrium constant is symbolized
by the letter k
and the equilibrium constant tells us
about the relative concentrations of
reactants and products
at equilibrium let's say we have a
hypothetical reaction where
reactants a and b turn into products
c and d and in the balanced equation the
lower case letters are the coefficients
so we have a lowercase a a lowercase b
lowercase c
and lowercase d as coefficients in our
balanced equation
if we were to write an equilibrium
constant expression for this
hypothetical reaction
we'd start by writing the equilibrium
constant k and then we have a subscript
c
here because we're dealing with
concentrations in our equilibrium
constant expression and the equilibrium
constant kc
is equal to in the in the numerator
we have the concentrations of our two
products multiplied together
and the concentration of each product is
raised to the power of the coefficient
in the denominator we have the
concentrations of the two reactants
multiplied by each other
and raised to the power each
concentration is raised to the power of
the coefficient
in the balanced equation it's important
to emphasize that the concentrations
that we're plugging into our equilibrium
constant expression
are equilibrium concentrations and when
we plug in our equilibrium
concentrations into our equilibrium
constant expression
we get a value for the equilibrium
constant k
and k is constant for a particular
reaction
at a certain temperature let's write an
equilibrium constant expression for the
following reaction which shows the
synthesis of
ammonia from nitrogen and hydrogen
and everything is in the gaseous state
we start by writing the equilibrium
constant kc
see because we're dealing with
concentrations and we start with our
product which is
ammonia so we write the concentration of
ammonia and we raise the concentration
of ammonia
to the power of the coefficient and the
balanced equation which is a two
so this is the concentration of ammonia
to the second power
then in the denominator we think about
our reactants
so we have nitrogen so we write the
concentration of
nitrogen and since the coefficient is a
one in the balanced equation that'd be
the concentration of nitrogen to the
first power
multiplied by the concentration of our
other reactant which is hydrogen so we
write in here
h2 and because there's a coefficient of
three in the balanced equation
we raise the concentration of hydrogen
to the third power
for gases it's often more convenient to
measure partial pressures
instead of measuring concentrations so
let's say
that a b c and d are all gases we could
write an equilibrium constant
expression using partial pressures
instead
of concentrations and if we did that
instead of writing kc
we would write kp where p stands for
pressure
and kc and kp usually have different
values from each other
so if we go back to our our previous
reaction where everything was in the
gaseous state we could write a kp
expression so we would write kp is equal
to
we think about products over reactants
so this would be the partial
pressure of our product ammonia
raised to the second power
divided by the partial pressure of
nitrogen
raised to the first power times the
partial pressure of
hydrogen raised to
the third power for the synthesis of
ammonia
everything was in the gaseous state and
when
all substances reactants and products
are in the same phase
we call this a homogeneous equilibrium
when the substances are in different
phases we call
it a heterogeneous equilibrium
for example in the decomposition of
calcium carbonate to turn into calcium
oxide and carbon dioxide
calcium carbonate carbonate is a solid
and calcium oxide is a solid
but carbon dioxide is a gas so we have
substances
in different phases when we write an
equilibrium
constant expression for a heterogeneous
equilibrium
we leave pure solids and pure liquids
out of the equilibrium constant
expression
so if we write an equilibrium constant
expression for the decomposition of
calcium carbonate
let's write a kc expression first here
so we write kc is equal to
and we think about products over
reactants
for products we have carbon dioxide in
the gaseous state so it's okay to
include that in our equilibrium constant
expression so we write the concentration
of
co2 and since the coefficient is a one
in the balanced equation this would be
the concentration of co2 raised to the
first power
our other product is a solid so we're
going to leave that out of
out of our equilibrium constant
expression and for our reactant calcium
calcium carbonate that's also a solid so
that's also left
out of our expression if we were to
write a kp
expression here we would include the
partial pressure
of our gas which is carbon dioxide so
this would be the partial pressure of
carbon dioxide to the first power
and once again we would leave the two
solids out of our
equilibrium constant expression the
reason why we leave pure solids and pure
liquids out of equilibrium constant
expressions for heterogeneous equilibria
is because the concentration of a pure
solid or a pure liquid remains
constant over time so it doesn't help us
to include it
in our equilibrium expression finally
let's talk about the reaction quotient
which is symbolized
by the letter q a q expression has the
same form as an equilibrium constant
expression
and q tells us the relative
concentrations of reactants and products
at any moment in time and just like we
could write
a kc or a kp expression we could write a
qc or a qp expression let's go back to
our reaction
for the synthesis of ammonia from
nitrogen gas
and hydrogen gas notice how the qc
expression has the same form as the kc
expression the difference is for the
casey expression all of our
concentrations
are equilibrium concentrations so i
could put an eq
here for the concentrations of ammonia
nitrogen and hydrogen
so for the kc expression it's only
equilibrium concentrations but for the
qc expression
it's the concentrations at any moment in
time
so that moment in time might be at
equilibrium
or it might not be at equilibrium
if qc is equal to kc the reaction
is at equilibrium but if qc is
greater than kc or if qc is less than kc
the reaction is not at equilibrium